[Music]
in Wayne there's more news submitted by
Steve's hairline chief met with
Starbucks to help an employee that was
fired for writing pig on his cup I saw
that I saw that what no no these
Starbuck employees like riding weird
[ __ ] on cups to like also the policemen
gotta like like oh this is for the pig
you know he was getting an order for
like his these guys I guess yeah and
then they wrote Pig goes literally not
even now though now look now your job
look I've been I've been to which which
there's a sandwich shop out here you
guys know where I ordered one from them
and they're savages all okay what I love
about which which though is that you can
write a name on a bag and they're gonna
say it out loud no matter what the name
is they're gonna say that name oh man I
don't believe in fairies [ __ ] you salami
sandwich for [ __ ] now here's me I've
been with him and I've been sitting
there I keep hearing somebody say like
Bartholomew Bartholomew and I see him
get up he won't faint he'll just get up
[ __ ] is he going about all this jackass
he's gonna get this smirk around people
who know me and then they're like who's
that I do I do reverse racism so we have
this restaurant in Alhambra called Savoy
and so they kind of do that where yep
there's always a waiting list and they
always come out and they read whatever
is on the clipboard and they all have
Asian essence because they're all like
50-year old ladies so I purposely by
like kung-fu master
come home don't even know what says it's
a kung fu master here this person was
just obviously very upset at police did
he know this person was black so they
don't mention that but see well first of
all I'll get there in a sec okay so this
is the police of the Chief of Police who
ended up posting on Facebook that his
coworker like another police officer
went to Starbucks and picked up like
five coffee cups that said they don it
so he was like this is so disrespectful
like because this is on Thanksgiving
what it feels like police intelligence
group Starbucks employee would have
flipped it like that out of gave it to
her you got it writing in the post what
irks me is the absolute and total
disrespect for a police officer who
instead of being home with family and
enjoying a meal and a football game is
patrolling his little town it wasn't a
good football game the whole session I
watched it me the game was that good but
here's the thing it's why you gotta look
at it from both perspectives cuz I don't
know what this person has been through
with policemen but at the same time be
professional you got your [ __ ] job
well yeah so that's the thing there's
this conspiracy theory that it if
Starbucks hasn't hit in their system a
whole bunch of words that you just can't
even put as a barista on any orders
because of so many issues like this yeah
so they're saying the only way you can
actually get pig on this order is if
they ordered it online so like they it
they put in pig themselves
that's the conspiracy interesting
anyway this story has a lot of police
juicy small aid themself yeah that's
good okay yeah yeah what about if
someone's actually main Pig and they
can't get a Starbucks thing now cuz
they're like can you give us a different
name Jimmy pike well yes so they ended
up firing that barista and not just that
barista but the manager who had nothing
to do with oh that's way fired is it man
at Starbucks a barista
huh barista the barista
so the manager gaffer you know how man
she's like what how many filters is ever
July a lot it just in case
Jessie case my I would put Casper on her
cup I put Casper or dr. Manhattan Jesus
Christ comic man I don't like people
acting out their own personal things but
regardless if it was conspiracy ER now I
don't like people acting out their own
personal issues at a workplace
manufacture if you just want to work at
Starbucks and you like cops take your
uniform off when you get off shits go
get a sharpie and go write Pig all over
their client in your own time but when
they're at work like behave as a priest
it's like you don't know that now this
woman and she could have kids you know
everything now is she's out of a job
like how is she gonna be able to afford
jewelry it's Claire's so Starbucks
Starbucks fired her yeah because they
think that well she's a manager yeah
like she should have been watching yes
so then she actually described her
interaction with the police officer that
I had the cup and said she said I handed
him his blueberry oh he said or she said
he laughed it off
said it was cool I handed him
blueberry muffin and I went back off the
floor and to continue my ship commander
duties manager this is what probably
happened then the cop that picked it up
thought it would be funny and then the
chief was like piss and he was like oh
[ __ ] I don't even know how that happened
crazy [ __ ] so this whole time you just
bite his tongue and he's like lying and
he's like holding it in and other people
are getting in trouble it's the way
police are covering things up now don't
do that the tuba police he ended up
meeting with Starbucks officials and
requested the young employee who was
terminated to be offered a position of
employment we start civility by
forgiving minor indiscretions and using
those moments to help people better
themselves this is a PR stunt for police
this is a straight PR style right right
yes Oklahoma so guys we're gonna fire
them but then we're gonna be you know
we're gonna sit down with them and have
compassion let them know that yeah we're
working in good with the bigger people
in this room guess what
this woman she claims to be the police
chief chief that what the [ __ ] the
police believe this woman is claiming to
be his daughter and she tweeted this
house it says this is my father and I'd
like to say that he is absolutely he is
absolutely a pig and I'd like to thank
the brave men and women from Starbucks
for their service wait this is the girl
guy the ropey no no this girl is
claiming to be the DA the daughter of
the police it's so funny what your kids
burn you out she's pretty much just in
my dad's stuff yeah
then she says for the record my father
has zero business being a police officer
he was blatantly proudly racist when I
was a kid said things I would never
repeat he treats women like dogs
including his own daughter she treats
his daughter like a pig like I was like
hey Dad I want to go all my friends he's
like no I'm like eh you treat me like a
pig like is this some rebellion [ __ ] you
dad you don't want to buy me the iPhone
she she called him out [ __ ] that's
pretty severe clearly she wrote this as
well
the deputy it actually happened to told
my mom he didn't really care and that it
was a harmless joke no big deal but my
father is a camera [ __ ] who couldn't
resist the attention okay so please when
kind of letting a laugh because he
probably hears that [ __ ] because she
said the guy who came and got it laughed
it off but then when she when he brought
it to the station one of the other
police officers well I'm a very petty
person so when I hear this daughter
doing this I'm kind of glad that she's
doubling down a lot lucky and go
although like I'm sending my old man
gifs of pigs every [ __ ] night really
triggers him I'm [ __ ] going in as
hard as I can I see my Thanksgiving I'm
I sent him a book of Charlotte's Web you
know ok so then all this happened right
so this made headlines again like what
the [ __ ] daughter of police chief is
saying that love love luck so all that's
happening but at the same time people
dug up her Twitter you know Twitter is
phenomenal making things up nice job
with all the twists of the story oh
thank you I
no no but you you have pasted very much
yeah because we think it's done and then
boom right we're back wait yeah I take a
Christopher Nolan are we watching
inception okay okay so this is what was
dug up and I'm really disappointed cuz I
even I like her Twitter I started
following her she's really funny but
this is not funny she ended up posting
this I can read this you can read it my
[ __ ] my [ __ ] my mother I've seen this
plenty of times by white women at this
point
look I'm not I'm not gonna race she's
using it the right way tags in clear
time uni uni it's like being approved
you know you need you gotta come to the
cookout she was the only white girl in
like the sea of black homies
and but we don't we don't know that we
have to know that what if she in the
picture in the picture oh my thing is
all about intent isn't it yeah like most
comedians are that way I could tell her
intent was it's very uh it's it's you
know she has no malice she heard the
song she was oh this would be a great
yeah what if she can prove with
photographic evidence that she has one
black friend or perhaps or perhaps a
half back foot yeah but she's obviously
still shitness
the mean responding to that I was a kid
and I grew up man I'm sorry for that but
I still never came close to the things
he used to say he said some truly
heinous [ __ ] that even back then I
couldn't believe anyone could say and I
can I couldn't agree with some of that
because I've said some wild [ __ ] of the
cave but every three years I'm ashamed
of who I used to be it's true
three three months
I'm ashamed of my future so moral of the
story is people are gonna still buy
Starbucks like that's the thing this
they're going this made them even bigger
oh yeah yeah they have no type of
marketing whatsoever it does it yeah
people market for themselves
I hope coffee bean takes them down oh
sure don't go get them good never happen
[Music]